all right welcome back to the show this
is such a crazy college football season
some might even question whether or not
games should be played during a pandemic
but
of course dollar signs split the
uprights and it's fans at home watching
on tv
they're the big winners tv numbers have
been big in spite of it all
unwill be closing out its season on the
islands playing in hawaii
of course the biggest bright spot for
the rebels all season long
has been their best player and that
would be running back
charles williams who knows if he'll be
back or
tried again maybe perhaps then caa says
he can come back
give it another ride but who knows if he
will nfl might override some of those
thoughts of returning for a normal
season
williams rushed for a game-high 148
yards yesterday
he scored two touchdowns unlv finished
his season though oh and
six looking forward to a productive off
season
by the way some schools have declined
bull bid invites some have not hawaii
nevada accepted bowl
bids hawaii will play in the new mexico
bowl but because of kobe in that state
they'll play it in texas reno will play
in the famous idaho potato bowl
that's in boise and the mountain west
championship will be played on december
19th at sam boyd stadium between
san jose and boise state